bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre en direct
les questions cribles thématiques
consacrées aujourd'hui à la question des
rythmes scolaires
alors qu'est ce que les questions
cribles thématiques et bien c'est une
série de questions posées par les
sénateurs à un membre du gouvernement
sur un sujet donné le sujet est donc
passé au crible
aujourd'hui et bien les sénateurs
interroge geneviève fioraso secrétaire
d'état à l'enseignement supérieur et à
la recherche sur la question des rythmes
scolaires
alors les rythmes scolaires c'est un
sujet récurrent ici au sénat qui a elle
même donné lieu à une mission spécifique
parmi les inquiétudes de nos élus et
bien les problèmes de financement des
activités périscolaires dans les
communes avec le risque que le temps
périscolaire ne devienne pas un temps de
garderie
faute de moyens tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle pour vos questions cribles à
l'initiative de la collectivité nous y
tenions qui peut recevoir l'appui des
services spécialisés de l'état renforcée
pour l'occasion
nous nous réjouissons tous ici bien sûr
de la pérennité des fonds de soutien
mais nous savons aussi que ça n'est pas
qu'une question d'argent mais aussi
peut-être une question de ressources
locales d'inventivité et de moyens
humains nous nous réjouissons aussi de
la mise en ligne d'une banque de
ressources en ligne visant à mettre à
disposition des communes une aide
méthodologique et des outils plus
nombreux madame la ministre la question
que nous nous posons et qu'il serait
important que ces outils soient
développées rapidement pour permettre à
tous ceux qui le souhaitent d'aller vers
la généralisation des pays endettés
du coup je vous pose la question de
savoir si un même recensement qui serait
a priori logique des nouvelles activités
périscolaires pourrait être imaginée sur
les mêmes bases de telle sorte que l'on
puisse à la fois avoir des échanges de
bonnes pratiques des modalités d'action
des coûts et aussi éventuellement
réfléchir à comment nous évaluions ses
activités qui sont mises en place par
les collectivités locales pour les
enfants de nos territoires
je vous remercie de votre réponse madame
la ministre pour vous répondre la parole
m
geneviève sera sous secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche
vous avez la parole même la ministre et
on vous accueilli avec plaisir
merci monsieur le président mais pour
que ce plaisir soit vraiment partagé
j'aurais d'abord vous adresser toutes
les excuses de najat vallaud belkacem
qui est retenue vous pouvez le
comprendre par les consultations liées à
la mise en oeuvre du plan cadre en
faveur de la laïcité et de
l'apprentissage des valeurs de la
république à l'école qu'elle a lancé ce
midi même et dont l on vous avez
sûrement pris connaissance je m'engage à
lui transmettre les remarques que
voudrait bien faire et à répondre de mon
mieux alors la circulaire à la mouche au
panama sénatrice et circulaires qui a
été élaboré à la fin de l'année dernière
avec l'ensemble des associations d'élus
locaux
les fédérations de parents d'élèves les
associations de jeunesse et d'éducation
populaire a marqué une étape mais vous
l'avez dit ce n'est pas suffisant elle a
marqué une étape parce que nous nous
sommes mis d'accord sur la
généralisation des projets éducatifs
territoriaux les ai eu d'été et sur
quelques principes simples qui faisait
encore défaut
le pdt est un outil simple un outil
souple qui peut s'adapter à la diversité
des situations locales et traduit la
construction progressive d'une offre
éducative locale cohérente porté par le
plus grand nombre et qui assure la
complémentarité des activités proposées
aux enfants
le pdt est un outil partement
partenariale à l'initiative de la
commune elle en prend l'initiative elne
en place un comité dessus de suivi avec
tous les partenaires en particulier les
familles est proposée critères
d'évaluation suivi dans la durée
cela garantit ainsi la maîtrise du
projet par les élus au bénéfice des
élèves et de leurs familles avec cette
circulaire nous avons également
réaffirmé que l'élaboration du pe d'été
est une démarche qui doit être davantage
accompagner par l'état il permettra aux
élus de proposer à chaque enfant dort
comme de leur commune
un parcours éducatif cohérent et de
qualité avant et après l'école pour
aller plus loin comme vous le souhaitez
à juste titre et les groupes d'appui
départementaux apporteront conseils et
accompagnement au plus près du terrain
notamment pour les maires des petites
communes et des communes loin des lieux
de ressources je veux dire les communes
rurales
par ailleurs la ministre de l'éducation
nationale a demandé au recteur et hoda
zen d'organiser des réunions avec les
associations d'élus pour les informer et
leur faciliter la tâche
enfin le travail d'apport de ressources
de mutualisation se matérialisera comme
vous l'avez souhaité dans la banque de
ressources en ligne annoncée dans la
circulaire celle ci verra le jour d'ici
la fin du mois de janvier et s'enrichira
progresse progressivement et
effectivement comme vous l'avez encore
proposé madame la sénatrice
nous ferons connaître les bonnes
pratiques les idées simples peu
coûteuses qui sont mises en place sur le
territoire national est adaptée à la
spécificité de chaque territoire
c'est absolument essentiel nous avons
fixé un objectif ambitieux 100% de
communes couvertes par le pdt d'ici la
fin de l'année et nous travaillons et
détermination pour atteindre cet
objectif
merci voir et plus que la parole et d'un
autre collègue corinne bouchoux nous
maîtrisions un peu le temps voilà
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues merci de cette
réponse qui me satisfait totalement et
je voulais dire que peut-être les
événements dramatiques de ces dernières
semaines peuvent nous conduire à
réfléchir pour les enfants à des
activités qui sont des activités qui
peuvent avoir lieu collectivement
posément utilisation d'internet lecture
de la presse et des activités qui sont
plutôt basé sur de la convivialité de la
coopération plutôt que basé sur de la
compétition et donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose que l'on peut retenir est
en tout cas un retour du terrain même
s'il ya eu des difficultés dans certains
endroits pour l'essentiel dans le
département du maine-et-loire des
trouvailles ont été faites et ça
fonctionne plutôt bien donc j'espère que
c'est aussi encourageant par tous je
vous remercie madame la ministre
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue michel le scouarnec pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
n'a si monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues penser un
projet pour l'école c'est penser un
projet pour la société pour son avenir
beaucoup reste à faire pour plus et
mieux d'école déchargement devait être
opéré mais le défi de répondre aux
inégalités culturelles et éducatives est
encore loin d'être gagnée après deux
années au moins en partie dans certaines
communes il serait opportun et
instructif de dresser un premier bilan
des activités proposées dans le cadre d'
étape afin d'y examiner l'implication
des équipes enseignantes
appréciation et la participation des
parents comptez-vous et allure dès la
fin de cette année une première
évaluation du dispositif
par ailleurs ces deux réformes a impacté
les collectivités tant au niveau
organisationnel que financier le coût
médian de trois heures d'activités
périscolaires s'élèverait à au moins 150
euros par enfant et par an avec des
variations selon les territoires à
l'image des îles ou des zones de
montagne
heureux les difficultés budgétaires se
conjugue avec celle géographique
le fonds d'amorçage même pérenniser ne
suffira pas aux communes déjà exemple
surtout les plus pauvres même si les
mutualisations dans certains secteurs
ont été un premier élément de réponse
que comptez vous faire pour que
simplement nos territoires puissent
assurer convenablement cette mission de
service public et surtout ne pas creuser
de nouvelles inégalités ce qui serait
dramatique
quel est l'apport du tissu associatif
local que dire aussi de la situation
d'emploi et de rémunération des
personnels recrutés pour quelques heures
encadrer les enfants nécessite une
formation adaptée et rétribuée à sa
juste valeur
quel espoir pouvez-vous donner à tous
ces acteurs qui agissent en faveur de la
réussite de nos enfants
pourriez-vous nous informer sur les
modalités d'exercice de leurs missions
et de contrat ma dernière question
portera sur l'évaluation du bénéfice
colère le servait fort même s'il est un
peu tôt pour tirer des conclusions
définitives qu'elle profite pour
l'apprentissage et la réussite des
enfants
ne fallait-il pas peut-être envisager
une réforme plus globale mieux concertée
et plus respectueuse des rythmes de vie
des enfants
je remercie merci pour vous répondre
sa parole est quand même geneviève
fioraso de la parole de la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur sénateur michel le scouarnec
merci tout d'abord d'avoir rappelé que
les réponses a amené à nos problèmes de
société et aux actes dramatique tragique
qui nous on frappe en ce début d'année
sont d'ordre global
je crois que c'est important de rappeler
même si aujourd'hui nous allons nous
concentrer sur les questions éducatives
qui sont quand même au coeur de l'avenir
de la société puisqu'elle concerne les
enfants donc d'aider avril 2013
puisque vous avez parlé d'évaluation un
comité national de suivi des rythmes
scolaires a été installé afin que nous
puissions établir au plus tôt mais dans
un délai tout de même raisonnable avec
le recul raisonnable les critères
d'évaluation identifier les effets
positifs mais aussi les points
d'amélioration et points de blocage a
levé ce comité devrait devrait être
remis à la ministre
courant février ce sera d'ailleurs le
second rapport d'étape au delà le
ministère de l'éducation assure via les
recteurs le suivi de l'impact des
nouveaux rythmes scolaires sur les
pratiques pédagogiques des enseignants
avec l'appui de l'inspection générale
ainsi que l'évaluation des
expérimentations mises en place au titre
du décret dit à mon un pilotage resserre
avec les partenaires de l'éducation
nationale le ministère de la jeunesse au
ministère de la famille et la cnaf est
également mise en place plusieurs
recherches sont initiés d'ailleurs avec
l'institut français d'éducation et
l'école d'économie de paris
sur les planches dpe d'été sur l'impact
de la réforme sur le travail des parents
et sur les effets des nouvelle
organisation du temps scolaire en
matière d'impact sur l'emploi local un
point que vous avez souligné nous ne
disposons pas encore de données
consolidées donc suffisamment crédibles
on estime le besoin d'emplois entre 75
milles et 200000 afin de répondre aux
demandes croissantes des collectivités
les temps libéré sur la semaine où le
recours à des groupements d'employeurs
ou à l'intercommunalité favorise
d'ailleurs les emplois à temps plein il
y a évidemment une forte attente en
termes de formation et qualification le
nombre de personnes s'orientant vers une
qualification non professionnels comme
le bafa mais aussi vers des
qualifications professionnelles
d'animateurs augmentent très
significatif signifierait tivement mon
collègue patrick kahn est remise de la
ville a initié un travail pour faciliter
davantage encore l'accès au diplôme
professionnel de l'animation pour les
jeunes c'est donc une filière d'avenir
et conclure mais même le menu free qu'il
s'agisse estimations de coût de la
réforme d'appréciation de son impact et
données sont encore parcellaires car
déclarative
il faut donc être être prudent le temps
d'évaluation est un temps nécessairement
long alors que la réforme des
généralisée que depuis moins de six mois
mais le premier ministre a annoncé un
premier point d'évaluation de la réforme
en juin 2015 sur les plans pédagogique
sur le plan de l'emploi et sur le plan
des ressources consacrées
bien pour vous répondre la parole à
michel le scouarnec brillement puisque
juste quelques mots pour ajouter dans le
merci peau précision madame la ministre
j'ai fait une tournée les voeux des
maires dans mon département et beaucoup
de maires sont félicités d'avoir réussi
à mettre en place de manière concertée
au niveau local il ya eu tous même des
inquiétudes par rapport aux financements
a exprimé dans toutes les communes et
également sur le doute par rapport à
l'efficacité la fatigue des enfants a
été évoqué un an beaucoup d'endroits
certains disent que les enfants ne
paraissent plus fatigué qu'avant donc
tout ceci devrait faire partie de leva
l'essonne
par contre tout le monde reconnaît que
de la culture en plus du sport en plus
sur des théories mans des facteurs de
réussite scolaire et je crois moi même
qui était enseignant beaucoup aux sports
aux activités culturelles et des travaux
manuels pour les enfants maintenant il
faut bien gérer le temps on service
qu'il faut qu'on gère mon cher collègue
maintenant comment j'ai pas entendu
gérer le temps oui voilà alors là ça ça
ça me coupe cissé yaya d'orgue la
réussite scolaires au bout qui est plus
importante et donc tout tout doit être
fait pour que nos enfants réussissent
vous savez bien
aujourd'hui c'est encore plus vrai que
hier et jour après jour mettant en
oeuvre la devise de la république
liberté égalité fraternité et ça dépend
de chacun d'entre nous merci la parole
est à notre collègue
même la présidente françoise cartron
pour le groupe socialiste vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre et mes chers collègues les
événements dramatiques que vous nous
venons de vivre ont mis en lumière
l'urgente nécessité de remettre au coeur
de l'école qui elle même est au coeur de
notre société
l'enseignement des valeurs républicaines
la connaissance de la laïcité
l'exercice de l'esprit critique et la
pratique de la tolérance
nous le savons la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
outre la réorganisation des temps
d'apprentissage a pour ambition de
proposer aux élèves une ouverture sur le
monde
deux complexes qui les entoure une
ouverture citoyenne culturel
environnemental ou sportives il est à
noter qu'aujourd'hui
l'association des maires de france par
la voix de son président recommande
d'inscrire dans les axes dpe d'été
l'acquisition des valeurs républicaines
mais nous le savons la qualité des
intervenants la qualité des ateliers des
activités proposées sont déterminantes
pour le succès de cette réforme et des
ambitions qu'elles portent
madame la ministre de l'éducation
nationale évoquée la semaine dernière de
nouvelles mesures afin de permettre que
l'école soit plus accessible aux
initiatives de tous les acteurs je
partage cet objectif et pense qu'il y a
là une place tout à fait essentiel pour
les associations de jeunesse et
d'éducation populaire
or nous le savons toutes les
associations se trouve aujourd'hui
confrontée à des difficultés certaines
de fonctionnement
ma question et dans la suivante face à
ce formidable défi de permettre aux
nouveaux rythmes scolaires d'être un
outil efficace au service de la
construction et de l'épanouissement des
enfants
quel accompagnement renforcé pour les
associations dont l'intervention se
rélève se révèle pertinente est
indispensable en complémentarité avec le
remarquable travail des enseignants et
pour vous répondre
vous avez la parole le ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
sainterie sénateurs damas sénatrice
françoise cartron
alors il faut le reconnaître jusqu'à
présent même si ce n'est pas le cas
partout
les associations ont encore été trop peu
mobilisé 1 en appui aux activités
périscolaires pour prendre en compte
leur volonté forte de participer à la
généralisation des ptt et pour leur
assurer une meilleure visibilité
l'ensemble des correspondants
départementaux du collectif des
associations partenaires de l'école
publique apparaîtront dans le cadre de
la banque des ressources en ligne mise
en place d'ici la fin du mois pour les
élus locaux
ce collectif regroupe environ 22
associations d'éducation populaire et
les mouvements pédagogiques présents sur
le territoire
pourront ainsi un mobiliser localement
leurs ingénieries d'accompagnement et de
formation en lien avec les groupes
d'appui départementaux animé par les
services de l'état
cette action partenariale doit être
soutenu qu'un des moyens financiers il
ya évidemment ceux des collectivités et
et grâce notamment grâce à la
contribution de l'état mais également
ceux du ministère de l'éducation
nationale lui-même qui priorise dans les
conventions pluriannuelles d'objectifs
conclues avec les grands réseaux
associatifs la mise en place d'une
ingénierie et d'une offre pour les
activités périscolaires d'autres moyens
peuvent être mobilisés sur des actions
spécifiques
ainsi dans le cadre du programme
d'investissements d'avenir un appel à
projets doté d'une enveloppe de 20
millions d'euros sera consacré à
l'apprentissage du numérique et au
discernement notamment par rapport à
internet un sujet très important dans la
période est de manière générale vous
l'avez dit aussi nous avons besoin
d'enseigner de faire vivre les valeurs
de la république
la citoyenneté la laïcité l'état à tout
son rôle à jouer et l'école un rôle
moteur à jouer
la ministre a présenté aujourd'hui même
ses orientations à l'issue de 15 jours
de consultations et a fait part d'une
mobilisation exceptionnelle de tous les
partenaires de l'école de la république
enfin l'association des maires de france
reçus par la ministre a appelé les
maires à inscrire dans les axes dpe de
dt l'acquisition des valeurs
républicaines
le président du réseau des villes
éducatrices a dit également ce travail
doit être prolongé dans les territoires
avec les élus avec les associations pour
passer véritablement à la phase
opérationnelle
un amendement est annoncée par la
ministre ce matin de 10 millions d'euros
aux associations pour toutes ces actions
périscolaires qui auront trait à la
citoyenneté et à l'apprentissage de la
laïcité plusieurs initiatives
associatives existe donc nous devons
aller plus loin et nous le ferons
ensemble
madame carton mes chers collègues
ministres merci pour ces informations
merci à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale de prévoir
justement cet accompagnement spécifique
pour ces associations regroupées dans
cette structure de cap et parce que à la
fois elle apporte comme vous l'avez dit
l'ingénierie pour la construction des
projets pe d'été et l'accompagnement
nécessaires des maires et des petits
maires en particulier de communes
rurales mais l oms
elles ont aussi la possibilité de
mobiliser des intervenants pour
lesquelles nous avons toutes garanties
et ça c'est important par rapport à
justement l'action qui sera la leur
auprès des jeunes enfants pour véhiculer
justement et faire partager ces valeurs
républicaines que nous remettons aux
qu'au coeur de notre projet de
l'éducation nationale et de
l'enseignement pour tous les enfants
merci merci ma chère collègue la parole
est maintenant françoise gatel pour le
groupe union des démocrates et
indépendants une aux centristes avaient
la parole mme asha collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues j'aurais
porté ici la voix des élus locaux à qui
l'état a imposé la mise en place de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires et nul ne
saurait mettre en cause l'engagement
conséquent des mains dans l'éducation
des enfants de france il faut
reconnaître que la réforme des rythmes
scolaires a été mise en place de manière
précipitée et sans étude d'impact
préalable et qu'elle contribue à creuser
des inégalités flagrantes entre d'une
part les écoles qui sont dotés de moyens
humains et financiers et d'autre part
celles qui ne le sont pas est également
accroître la fracture territoriale entre
le milieu rural et le milieu urbain à ce
titre je regrette vivement que les
interventions de mes collègues alertant
le gouvernement lors de ce projet n'ait
été entendues notamment l'occasion des
débats sur la refondation de l'école
dans la mesure où la proposition de
madame catherine morin desailly et
française ferrat de consacrer l'année
2013 2014 à une expérimentation n'a pas
été retenue il me semble aujourd'hui
absolument indispensable qu'une mission
d'évaluation de cette réforme sous le
contrôle de la commission des affaires
culturelles puissent être lancées dans
les meilleurs délais en outre en tant
que président de l'association
départementale des maires
d'ille-et-vilaine je suis interpellé
madame la ministre par des questions
extrêmement concrète est extrêmement
pratique sur la faisabilité des
initiatives en ille-et-vilaine l'urssaf
a adressé à certaines communes une
précision sur les conditions de recours
à des intervenants extérieurs
de type auto entrepreneur ou même
association
l'urssaf a indiqué à ces mères que ce
recours était impossible sous la forme
d'honoraires puisqu'en fait il y a un
lien de subordination entre la commune
et ses auto entrepreneur ou ses
intervenants puisque c'est la commune
qui fixe les conditions d'intervention
les programmes est également met à
disposition les locaux
donc madame la ministre beaucoup de
maires de france ont essayé d'être très
novateur dans les activités qui sont
mises en place et ont recours à des
activités extérieures pour proposer des
programmes de qualité
si l'interprétation de l'urssaf d'ille
et vilaine est confirmée ceci veut dire
madame la ministre que nos collègues ne
pourront plus faire appel à ces
intervenants puisque leurs interventions
seront requalifiés en tant que travail
salariés vont donc augmenter les charges
de 45 %
donc madame la ministre il est
extrêmement important qu'au delà des
objectifs louables pour l'avenir nous
ayons des réponses concrètes merci
madame aime bien je demande à tout le
monde de contracter son temps parce que
je souhaite que les neuf acteurs
puissent passer bien madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
sénatrice et inter madame la sénatrice
françoise gatel l'enjeu de l'évaluation
de cette réforme des rythmes scolaires
est évidemment essentiel été mise en
place avec un double objectif améliorer
les apprentissages fondamentaux chez les
élèves et réduire les inégalités
sociales dans l'activité dans l'accès
aux activités périscolaires
d'ailleurs la commission sénatoriale de
la culture de l'éducation de la comique
et de la communication y travaillent
dans le cadre plus global de
l'évaluation de la boîte refondation de
l'école de la république et je salue ce
travail commun madame morin desailly et
à madame fera dès avril 2013
un comité national de suivi des rythmes
scolaires a été installé sous la
présidence de la rectrice de lyon on y
associant tous les partenaires y compris
les partenaires de la recherche avec eux
une grille de critères étaient mises en
place qui permet d'évaluer la réforme
sous toutes ses facettes c'est un
travail qui est longe les dit tout à
l'heure puisque l'observation
l'évaluation ne peuvent s'inscrire que
dans la durée pour illustrer des effets
significatifs il fallait attendre que
les dispositifs soient stabilisés
sur le terrain vous avez également par
ailleurs sur le plan pédagogique ça
répond à une question précédente les
retours des 4000 première commune à
avoir mis en place les rythmes en 2013
nous ont permis d'apprécier tout de même
que les apprentissages fondamentaux et
est mieux positionnée au moment la
capacité d'attention des élèves était la
plus vive et que la matinée
supplémentaire donné effectivement de la
souplesse aux enseignants équipes
éducatives
vous avez soulevé un second problème lié
au statut des animateurs qui
interviennent dans les activités
périscolaires et qui ont opté pour le
statut d'auto entrepreneur c'est une
difficulté juridique qui n'avait pas été
anticipée et que nous avons soumises à
madame carole delga ma collègue du
commerce et de l'artisanat ses services
juridiques se penche sur le sujet pour
nous donner une réponse satisfaisante et
éviter évidemment un surcoût pour les
communes comme vous l'avez signalé
notamment de l'urssaf
quant à ce personnel qui pour être
entrepreneur d'un auto-entrepreneur n'en
est pas moins très qualifiés j'allais
faire monsieur le président dès que nous
aurons le retour je ne manquerai pas de
vous en tenir informés bon répliqué en
quelques secondes absolument le
président je compte vraiment sur une
réponse de précise madame la ministre
que cette question venant d'île et
vilaine est je crois une question qui
sera généralisé à l'ensemble du
territoire elle extrêmement importante
merci merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
catherine tremblay pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire mais la
parole monsieur collègue monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues après les incidents liés à la
minute de silence dans les
établissements scolaires je me dois de
commencer mon propos en rappelant que la
place primordiale qu'occupent les colts
dans notre république
s'il est nécessaire de réaffirmer que la
mission notre école est d'instruire les
enfants et de les accompagner sur le
chemin de la citoyenneté
cela exige obligatoirement la
transmission du respect des valeurs
républicaines le respect de la france à
préalable qu'il faut également réaffirmé
ce le respect des enseignants ces
derniers ont besoin d'être soutenus et
paul et écoutez il faut rétablir la
relation maître élève mais aussi gommer
les différences à l'école la situation
est grave c'est la raison pour laquelle
le groupe ump du sénat
très réactif a demandé la création d'une
pardon une commission d' enquête sur les
menaces qui pèsent sur l'école de la
république
revenons-en au sujet du jour les rythmes
scolaires gommer les différences à
l'école disait madame la ministre il ya
quelques secondes
et bien après un premier bilan d'étape
on peut dire que l'objectif recherché
par les nouvelles activités
périscolaires qui se voulait lutter
contre les inégalités sociales tendent
pendant presque entière des communes
françaises à les accentuer
faute d'un financement adapté au coût
réel de ce nouveau service imposé aux
communes puisque entre 63 et 175 euros
reste à la charge des communes par an et
par enfant selon une récente enquête de
la cnaf en coopération avec
l'association des maires de france et
bien 29 % de celle-ci prévoit des
activités payantes fréquenté par
seulement 35 % moyenne des élèves c'est
à dire ceux dont les parents peuvent
payer les activités et que dire des
écoles ou n'est organisé que de la
garderie ou encore celle rien du tout
net organisé après les cours où est
l'égalité des chances vous vanter les
mérites des nappes mais pour les
communes qui n'ont vraiment pas les
moyens de les organiser
qu'allez-vous faire madame la ministre
la parole madame la ministre pour
répondre à la grande bleue
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice catherine trône le
j'ai effectivement bien entendu les
objectifs que vous avez annoncé les
grands objectifs cadres et je crois
pouvoir dire pour avoir assisté à la
conférence participer à la conférence de
presse de la ministre de l'éducation
nationale ce matin que vous avez les
mêmes objectifs
la conclusion de votre préalable sera un
peu différente dans la mesure où nous ne
souhaitons pas en rajouter un climat
anxiogène qui ne serait pas bon
d'ailleurs pour l'éducation des enfants
et nous souhaitons apporter des comme
vous je le pense des solutions
constructives et au contraire ressuscité
l'espoir puisque c'est bien de cela
qu'il s'agit
pour assurer la réussite des enfants et
de tous les enfants de tous milieux
comme vous l'avez dit manat sénatrice je
vous en remercie en ce qui concerne les
coûts des activités périscolaires
j'ai vu comme vous les analyses des
coups qui ont été publiés par la haye
mais fulham gvf et qui affiche des
surcoûts pour les communes par rapport
aux aides de l'état nous ne pouvons pas
le nier c'est pourquoi l'état était
présent dès 2013 pour accompagner les
communes à travers le farce
en plus des aides dz de existantes et
désormais à travers le fonds de soutien
aux communes ce fonds est désormais
pérenniser ce fonds est pérennisée comme
s'y était engagé le premier ministre
depuis la généralisation de la réforme
je le rappelle ce sont 400 millions
d'euros qui ont été programmées chaque
année dans le budget de l'état pour
soutenir les communes ce niveau des der
conduit c'est l'assurance je crois qu
attendait les élus es laquelle le
gouvernement a répondu avec le soutient
d'ailleurs de votre haute assemblée à
travers cet ept vous le savez nous avons
six choisi d'aider davantage les
communes le plus en difficulté une aide
spécifique de 40 euros par élève et par
an s'ajoutent ainsi à l'aide forfaitaire
pour les communes de l'outre-mer et
celles classées en déçu et en dsr cible
au delà de l'état la branche famille est
également mobilisée à compter de 2015 ce
sont 250 millions d'euros annuels qui
sont prévus dans le budget de la cnaf
l'accompagnement de l'état n'est pas
seulement financier nous avons engagé un
vrai dialogue avec toutes les
associations d'élus locaux dont
l'association des maires ruraux pour
accompagner la réforme et pour
introduire les assouplissements
nécessaires à sa mise en oeuvre efficace
et égalitaire sur tous les territoires
merci madame promeut martha coakley oui
très rapidement monsieur le président
madame la ministre je vous remercie de
cette réponse je voudrais simplement
vous rappeler que si effectivement ce
fonds a été pérennisée
c'est grâce aux moult relance qui ont
été faites par le groupe ump par les
élus du groupe ump tout particulièrement
par une proposition de loi que nous
avions déposé qui n'avait obtenu aucun
écho de la part du gouvernement
mais finalement le gouvernement a dû
plier et monsieur le premier ministre a
dû annoncer qu'il y avait effectivement
une pérennisation et on vous en félicite
c'est effectivement ce qu'on a attendu
pour autant madame la ministre vous
n'avez absolument pas répondu à ce
qu'elles sont les objectifs recherchés
en finale pour les petites communes qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas les moyens
financiers de faire et qu'avec même
cette aide là elles n'arriveront pas à
mettre en place
où est l'égalité des chances merci
chers collègues parole est maintenant
notre collègue françoise laborde pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
la question des rythmes scolaires a été
largement est régulièrement abordé sur
nos bancs les spécialistes des rythmes
de l'enfant s'accordent sur les
bienfaits d'un retour à la semaine de
quatre jours et demi néanmoins la
question du financement des activités
périscolaires par les collectivités se
posent encore la loi de finances pour
2015 à pérenniser le fonds d'amorçage
devenu un véritable fonds de soutien aux
communes et aux yeux pci cet effort doit
cependant être mis en perspective avec
la baisse globale des dotations aux
collectivités et avec le coût réel des
activités périscolaires pour ces
dernières mais ma question pose sur un
aspect bien précis autour du décret 2014
mais 320 du 3 novembre 2014
ce dernier définit à son article 1er
l'accueil de loisirs extra scolaires
comme celui qui se déroule les jours où
il n'y a pas d'école et l'accueil de
loisirs périscolaire comme celui qui se
déroule les jours où il y as écoles
cette distinction est source de
difficultés pour certaines collectivités
en effet dans de nombreux cas dans de
nombreux cas pardon les activités
périscolaires en lien direct avec les
écoles sont du ressort des communes
alors que les activités extrascolaires
relève de l'intercommunalité avec
l'objectif de mutualisation de ses
missions une application stricte de ce
décret aurait des conséquences fâcheuses
par exemple les enfants dans les
communes sans accueil périscolaire se
verraient privés d'activités le mercredi
après midi
ma question est donc simple comptez-vous
assouplir les conditions d'application
dudit décret afin de permettre aux
collectivités d'organiser au mieux
l'articulation entre ces deux temps je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre avait la
parole monsieur car ces mini break un
journaliste
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice françoise laborde la
généralisation de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires conduit désormais appliqué un
régime différent vous l'avais dit aux
accueils périscolaires aux accueil
extrascolaire notamment au niveau des
taux d'encadrement des enfants
le décret du 3 novembre dernier qui a
été longuement concertée que les
associations d'élus a précisé que
l'accueil de loisirs périscolaire et
celui qui se déroule les jours où il y
as écoles les accueille jusqu alors
organisées les mercredis après midi sont
donc passer de la catégorie extra
scolaires à la catégorie périscolaire et
bénéficie donc des dispositions
réglementaires spécifiques dès lors
qu'ils sont organisées dans le cadre
d'un projet éducatif territorial
c'était une mesure de souplesse attendu
des élus qui nous demandait depuis
plusieurs mois ces mesures de
simplification ce faisant cette
modification a pu avoir à certains
endroits un impact sur la répartition
des compétences entre les communes et
les opci
il faut rappeler que nous sommes là dans
le champ des compétences facultatives
des communes et des opci
ce n'est donc pas la loi qui fixe la
répartition de compétences mais bien les
élus eux mêmes en fonction de leurs
besoins et de leurs contraintes qui
peuvent donc les faire évoluer
je n'ignore pas que des élus ont été
surpris et ont manqué de temps pour
s'organiser et anticiper les changements
toutefois il ne s'agit pas créer des
zones d'incertitude qui sont autant de
questionnements sur la responsabilité
des uns et des autres notre objectif
avec le ministre patrick kanner consiste
ce bien aider les élus à organiser au
mieux les activités périscolaires nous
avons aussi conscience que l'année
scolaire étant déjà très avancé les
organisations mises en place ne peuvent
être bousculées facilement nous
donnerons donc avant la fin du mois de
janvier des consignes au préfet pour
qu'il réponde de façon pragmatique et
fassent preuve de souplesse sur le
maintien des organisations en place
jusqu'à la fin de cette année scolaire
mais nous demandons que ce temps 10 6
mois de juin soit ni pleinement à profit
pour que dans les territoires concernés
les élus redéfini ses responsabilités de
chacun et en particulier ceux concernant
la prise en charge des enfants le
mercredi après midi
la démarche des périodes et est
activement soutenue par l'état invite
évidemment à cette réflexe à cette
réflexion qui devra aboutir avant la
rentrée scolaire prochaine mais aussi
par l'état
notre collègue françoise laborde merci
madame la ministre vos propos viennent
d'apporter je pense une réponse
satisfait
quant aux interrogations de nombreuses
collectivités et donc bien sûr cette
réponse sera largement diffusé et dans
ma réplique je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur les conséquences du décret
du 7 mai 2014 qui a permis et qui permet
des assouplissements adapté aux réalités
locales
ainsi certaines communes ont fait le
choix d'organiser les activités
périscolaires sur deux après midi à
hauteur d'une heure trente
par contre d'autres groupes les 3 heures
sur la seule après-midi du vendredi
après midi donc les réflexes herbe
exprimées par certains chronobiologistes
de cet aménagement est complètement
contraire à l'esprit de la réforme et il
entraîner l'absence de certains enfants
dont les parents substitue un
enseignement religieux aux activités
périscolaires ou tout simplement la
tentation de partir deux jours et demi
en week-end je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à
monsieur le questeur dominique bailly
pour le groupe socialiste l'avait la
parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
la france notre république laïque a été
visée en ce début d'année par des
attaques terroristes et je crois que la
séance d'aujourd'hui est l'occasion de
rappeler que l'école et doit être le
lieu de transmission de ces valeurs de
nos valeurs de la république pour nos
futurs citoyens que sont nos enfants
le gouvernement a mis en oeuvre cette
réforme des rythmes scolaires qui a pour
objectif oui d'améliorer les
apprentissages de tous les élèves mais
aussi de lutter contre les inégalités
scolaires
je crois sincèrement pelé rythme que ces
nouveaux rites peuvent être un outil au
service de la grande mobilisation de
l'école pour les valeurs de notre
république qui évoqué notre collègue
liberté égalité fraternité que madame
vallaud belkacem appelle de ses voeux et
que je crois surtout c'est bon nous
relayons j'en viens à présent au coeur
de ma question au cours de l'examen du
budget 2015 oui vous l'avez évoqué un
chers collègues la pérennisation du
fonds d'amorçage a été actée par le
gouvernement ainsi que la nécessité bien
sûr de mettre en place un
roger éducatif territorial je souhaite
donc madame la ministre vous interroger
sur trois poids rapidement sur le
président en est point concernant
l'accompagnement financier de l'état si
le fonds de soutien est versée aux
communes assez rapidement un tiers en
fin d'année civile deux tiers en fin
d'année scolaire les versements de la
caf interviennent eux
après plus d'une année donc en décalage
et pouvant entraîner oui des problèmes
de trésorerie pour certaines communes
pouvez vous madame la ministre
m'indiquer les pistes d'amélioration en
la matière deuxième point concernant
l'élaboration des ptt
je vous en parle d'expérience pour
l'avoir mis en place dans ma commune
c'est un outil indispensable mais oui
lourd lourd à mettre et à construire
le ministère a dernièrement adresse un
courrier au maire les assurant de la
mobilisation des services troisième
territoriaux de l'état en la matière
pouvez-vous préciser la nature et les
modalités de cet accompagnement
madame la ministre je conclus troisième
point concernant les recrutements des
animateurs là aussi retours du terrain
il peut y avoir quelques difficultés
pour les communes de jongler entre un
besoin de souplesse c'est normal avec
toute cette diversité des thématiques
mais aussi les règlements inhérentes à
la fonction publique en matière de
recrutement
le ministère dispose t-il d'éléments de
remontées de terrain sur les bilans en
la matière je vous remercie de votre
attention pour vous répondre la parole
et à madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les cintres hisser et
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur dominique
bailly je voudrais vous remercier tout
d'abord d'avoir souligné que les
services de l'état se sont attachés à
verser rapidement les aides aux communes
pour l'exercice 2014 2015 ce sont près
de 22000 600 communes qui ont reçu dès
la fin du mois d'octobre pour raconte
près de 124 millions d'euros et 256
millions d'euros seront versés dans le
courant du mois de mars prochain
je connais les incompréhensions qui se
sont exprimés vis-à-vis de la cnaf
mais je veux aussi vous dire que depuis
cet été elle a engagé la simplification
de ces dispositifs est elle à alléger
et le nombre de pièces justificatives à
fournir nous travaillerons encore avec
sa direction pour apporter s'il le faut
de nouvelles réponses de simplification
aux élus qui le demandent
concernant l'accompagnement mise en
place par l'état nous avons avec patrick
kanner demande aux services de l'état
d'apporter conseils accompagnement plus
près du terrain en privilégiant
particulièrement les maires des petites
communes et des communes rurales
ce sera le rôle des groupes d'appui
départementaux que nous avons réactivé
et renforcer la semaine dernière le
ministère d'éducation nationale a
demandé au recteur d'académie et hoda
zen d'organiser des réunions que les
associations d'élus pour bien connaître
leurs attentes et leurs besoins et y
répondre de la façon la plus précise
possible accompagner les élus c'est
aussi leur apporter de nouvelles
ressources et porté à leur connaissance
les bonnes idées qui ont émergé au cours
de ces derniers mois
c'est ce travail d'apport de ressources
et de mutualisation de sénateurs qui se
matérialisera notamment dans la banque
de ressources en ligne déjà évoqué les
maires pourront aussi trouver une aide à
la rédaction et à l'ingénierie des ptt
enfin concernant le recrutement des
animateurs je suis consciente qu avec la
montée en charge rapide le de la réforme
le recrutement d'un grand nombre
d'animateurs n'a pas toujours été facile
les besoins sont très importants les
chiffres le plus souvent cités varie de
75 mille à 200000 emplois notre
préoccupation est à la fois de répondre
aux demandes des collectivités qui
veulent recruter et de veiller à la
qualité de l'emploi à laquelle est
étroitement liée aux organisations mises
en place localement il ya une forte
attente en termes de formation et de
qualification le nombre de personnes
s'orientant vers une qualification
nos professionnels comme le bafa mais
aussi lors des qualifications
professionnelles d'animateurs augmente
significativement
mon collègue patrick kanner a d'ores et
déjà initié un coup coupure pour
faciliter l'accès au diplôme
professionnel de l'animation pour les
jeunes à travailler conduit également
avec le cnfpt pour que nous puissions
répondre au mieux et plus rapidement aux
attentes des employeurs locaux en termes
de qualification et de formation
professionnelle au service de la
réussite des enfants pour une bonne
culture pays
moi je voudrais saluer la réactivité du
gouvernement
et oui une telle réforme qui a
bouleversé je ne peux pas répondre
monsieur le président au manifester
votre volonté une telle une telle
réforme bien sûr elle est bouleversée
certaines habitudes et donc elle a
engendré naturellement des difficultés
d'application
et oui je voudrais saluer la réactivité
du gouvernement qui point après point
essaie de répondre pour accompagner les
maires les élus locaux car et je conclus
lorsqu il y a la volonté politique la
réussite est au bout du chemin mes chers
collègues
merci la parole est là notre collègue
jean françois husson pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire madame
maintenir son temps pour madame la
ministre mes chers collègues dans ces
heures graves pour notre république
nous devons regarder les choses en face
la réalité des faits avec une grande
lucidité
c'est dans le gouvernement républicain
que l'on a besoin de toute la puissance
de l'éducation je cite montesquieu oui
l'école est aujourd'hui en première
ligne pour faire vivre notre république
oui de nombreuses épreuves réponse
pardon sont d'abord éducative
concernant la réforme des rythmes
scolaires nombreuses sont les questions
que j'avais soulevé liens auprès de
monsieur peillon à être restée sans
réponse
était ce bien là le chantier prioritaire
à ouvrir que d'énergie dépensée et de
perturbations créées et pour quel
résultat
contrairement à l'ambition affichée
cette réforme se révèle clairement
porteuse inégalités entre les
territoires
le fonds de soutien désormais pérenniser
après un long combat n'est destinée
qu'aux communes qui mettent en place des
activités qu est il alors prévue pour
les communes qui n'en n'ont pas les
moyens matériels ou rencontrent de
réelles difficultés
le fonds de soutien est conditionnée à
l'existence d'un projet éducatif de
territoire ce document dont je souligne
l'intérêt à la valeur peut néanmoins
être extrêmement difficile à bord et
pour certaines communes un
accompagnement local est il prévu afin
qu'ils ne soient pas pénalisés à la
prochaine entrée quelle importance
donnerait vous dansez eux
et et à l'apprentissage des valeurs qui
fondent notre pacte républicain et je
pense notamment bien sûr à la laïcité
mais aussi au respect ou à la fraternité
apprentissage dont j'estime qu'il enlève
d'abord de la responsabilité de l'état
et pour lequel nous devons être
collectivement plus exigeants en
permettant notamment aux enseignants
d'être mieux formés pour réagir aux
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent enfin et
pour permettre de repartir du bon pied
et de s'engager dans la bonne direction
il est nécessaire d'évaluer
rigoureusement et objectivement cette
réforme
foucault q comment avez-vous prévu
d'évaluer sa mise en place
coût de la réforme mobilisation des
financements intérêts de la mise en
place d'activités en maternelle et
analyse des raisons pour lesquelles
certaines communes n'ont pu accéder à
ces activités et enfin quelle évaluation
de son impact réel et 4 amélioration
constatée pour les enfants à la fin du
primaire bien madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean françois husson
j'ai pas revenir sur la pertinence ou
non de la réforme la pertinence est
avéré je vous ai dit des premiers outils
dès les premières étapes d'évaluation
montrait un progrès dans l'acquisition
de connaissances et nous aurons une
connaissance parfaite de l'évaluation
d'ici le mois de juin
le premier ministre s'est engagé devant
l'association des maires de france
j'ai bien noté la crainte de certains
élus locaux c'est vrai il faut pas la
nier que l'outil du des projets
éducatifs territoriaux soient complexes
parfois à mettre en place nous avons mis
tous nos efforts le ministère ces
services les partenaires ont mis leurs
meilleurs efforts pour simplifier
l'outil surtout pour qu'il puisse être
adapté aux spécificités de chaque
territoire des outils d'accompagnement
en ingénierie ont été mises en place je
les dis il va y avoir un dispositif en
ligne qui va permettre de peut-être
mettre à jour cinq ou six modèles
différents et qui seront applicables
avec des spécificités mais moi je ce qui
me dit faire peut-être de votre état
d'esprit c'est que moi je fais confiance
dans l'intelligence collective des élus
locaux parce que je sais que ils sont
convaincus surtout à la lueur des
événements tragiques qui sont déroulés
ce mois ci qu'il faut agir qu'il faut
agir sur les
cole qu'il faut agir dans le temps
périscolaire qu'il faut agir auprès des
enfants pour qu'ils s'imprègnent
davantage des principes républicains des
principes de laïcité et je sais qu'ils
ont à coeur de réussir de réussir ce
dispositif
loin de tout préjugé loin de toute
idéologie ils ont envie que cela marche
et notre administration nos
administrations mettront toute la
souplesse nécessaires elles l'ont déjà
fait toutes leurs capacités d'adaptation
pour que cette mise en oeuvre soit
possible sur l'ensemble des territoires
ruraux urbains périurbains alors sur le
suivi en ligne j'allais dire mais au fil
de l'eau évidemment nous avons mis en
place tout un système dans les rectorats
avec les dizaines pour pour collecter au
fur et à mesure tous les éléments qui
seront analysées et et communiqués d'ici
là - le mois de juin
j'aurais simplement dire un mot sur la
formation des enseignants parce que
brièvement très brièvement
monsieur le président je comprends que
vous ayez envie que peut-être je serai
un peu brio j'ai envie que tout le monde
sauf
d'accord je remercie le seul président
mais tout de même la formation par le
comportement par le contact avec les
élèves et par la professionnalisation
avait été largement réduite est abîmée
lors du quinquennat précédent dont nous
l'avons rétabli et nous l'avons établi
et où le soin et la pluralité nécessaire
l'acquisition disciplinaire mais aussi
l'acquisition de l'acquisition qui est
hors discipline j'allais dire qui est
dans le contact dans l'apprentissage la
citoyenneté des enfants et c'est bien
cela que nous voulons inculquer aux
enseignants dans les écoles supérieures
de formation des enseignants qui se met
en place aujourd'hui avec des moyens
supplémentaires et surtout un état
d'esprit différent
plusieurs sont brièvement williams la
ministre hoti de l'intelligence
collective
d'abord je veux souligner l'implication
des associations d'élus que ce soit
autour du président de l'anef notre
collègue françois baroin de caroline
cayeux pour les villes de france
simplement parfois les élus ne voient
pas tout à fait le lien entre la réforme
dite des rythmes scolaires et le fait
que quatre écoliers sur dix à la fin du
primaire sortent sans acquis de qualité
des fondamentaux ou
cent cinquante mille de nos jeunes
sortent du système éducatif sans
qualification
c'est une des questions importantes puis
la deuxième elle est aussi importante
c'est qu'on voit aujourd'hui que la
conception de l'éducation commission
partage et s'affirme progressivement
et pourtant la décentralisation
éducative est marqué par un partage de
compétences dont la clarté ne nous
paraît pas évidente et je voudrais enfin
vous dire ne gâchons pas ensemble la
l'énergie de la chaîne éducative
parce que votre ministère enfin celui de
la ministre que j'aurais eu plaisir à
accueillir est d'abord aussi peut-être
celui de l'instruction publique
merci vos chers collègues la parole et à
notre collègue daniel chagrin pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la question
des rythmes scolaires a fait bien sûr
l'objet de bien des polémiques
à titre personnel en tant que maire
d'une commune rurale rézé mis en place
au début ça n'a pas été facile
bon je le regrette pas bien que cela
présente tout de même un coût de 150
euros par enfant et par an cela bien sûr
s'ajoutant à la diminution annoncée de
la dgf de 30 % aux communes en tant que
président d'une association
départementale de mer j'ajouterai un
département rural où très rurale un
certain nombre de questions me sont
remontés de la base je les résument en
trois questions une interrogation la
première concerne les très petites
communes territoriales et les
regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux rpi qui ont parfois du
mal à mettre en oeuvre le plan éducatif
et qui de ce fait ne reçoivent rien
puisque l'aide de l'état est conditionné
au pe d'été deuxième question la
deuxième est qu'il en est de même si le
pe d'été ne comporte pas de projets
éducatifs concret détaillé ce qui est
très difficile pour une petite commune
la troisième concerne la lsh l'accueil
de loisirs sans hébergement si une
commune n'en possède pas eh bien il n'y
a aucune aide de la caf
ma question est donc la suivante madame
la ministre
comment
régler ses problèmes enfin ma seconde
interrogation et je pense commune à tous
ceux qui siègent dans l'hémicycle
cela a été dit le gouvernement entend il
pérennise et les 50 euros obtenus par la
mobilisation de la mf au delà de 2015
merci madame le mise de votre réponse
merci madame la ministre et la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs sénatrices et sénateurs mais
ce sénateur daniel chassaing d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier vous remercier
de votre propos liminaire
qui était sincère qui émane d'un d'un
élu de terrain qui dit que bien qu'étant
dans un secteur rural
oui il a pris la peine dès le début de
monter un projet malgré les difficultés
chevaux jour merci
alors j'ai commencé peut-être par votre
dernière question comme s'y est engagé
le premier ministre lors du dernier
congrès de la mf nous avons pérennisé le
fonds d'amorçage et l'engagement pris
par le premier ministre et la ministre
de l'éducation nationale a été tenu que
celui ci est devenu dans la loi de
finances pour 2015 le front de soutien
en commune pour l'organisation des
activités périscolaires donc vous pouvez
rassurer les communes et les élus qui
vous ont posé cette question quant à la
pérennisation de l'aide de 50 euros
au total c'est donc je le rappelle un
engagement de 400 millions d'euros pour
2014-2015 et les communes qui mettent en
place un accueil de mineurs déclarés
peuvent également percevoir l'aide de la
cnaf de 54 euros
comme vous le rappelez le parlement
recul principe du conditionnement de
l'aide de l'état la signature d'un pee
d'été mais encore une fois on n'est pas
dans une procédure bureaucratique unique
pour tous et nous saurons nous adapter
aux configurations spécifiques en
territoire très rural si on nous montre
une photographie de l'existant avec une
marge d'adaptation et de progression
dans le temps et bien naturellement cela
sera acceptée je crois qu'il faut avoir
du bon sens et avoir le souci de
l'efficacité final plutôt que d'avoir
une procédure unique réglementaire et
qui soit la même pour tous les
territoires
ce qui ne serait pas du tout adaptés et
qu'ils nous auraient pas atteindre
l'objectif poursuivi donc je veux vous
rassurer
oui il ne sera pas nécessaire d'avoir un
peu d'été très très détaillée pour
certaines communes rurales
nous accepterons un plan encore une fois
avec une marge de progression et des
objectifs identifiés et et mesurables
c'est ce qui nous permet beaucoup
d'amour oui c'est ce qui nous permettra
d'augmenter le nombre de communes
rurales que vous serez avec nous
persuader de mener leur projet éducatif
territorial parce que c'est possible et
surtout parce que c'est utile pour les
enfants et que notamment les principes
encore une foi de laïcité d'éducation
civique d'appartenance à la république
pourront être dispensés très utilement
je remercie d'y contribuer mais c'est le
sénateur sur le sénateur la corrèze à
lévis pour quelques secondes
merci monsieur le président donc je
souhaite que les 50 euros soit pérennisé
au delà de 2015 bien sûr et vous avez
dit madame le ministre
un outil souple j'espère que ce sera le
cas pour que les petites communes
puissent en bénéficier ce qui est loin
d'être le cas actuellement
en tout cas vous avez dit qu'ils avaient
ignoré des y aurait des réunions au
niveau des recteurs et des associations
des maires de france
nous ne manquerons pas bien sûr de le
faire part aux recteurs merci merci
madame la ministre
merci de votre présence mes chers
collègues l'ensemble des questions ont
pu être transmises et ça n'est qu'un
début
je vais maintenant su sport de la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi
voilà pour cette séance de questions
cribles thématiques consacrées
aujourd'hui à la question est bien des
rythmes scolaires pendant 45 minutes
vous avez pu entendre geneviève fioraso
secrétaire d'état à l'enseignement
supérieur et à la recherche
répondre aux sénateurs alors les
événements du début du mois de janvier
on était évidemment très présent dans
cette session le certains sénateurs
comme la sénatrice socialiste françoise
cartron ont demandé à la ministre est
bien de mettre les valeurs républicaines
au coeur de l'école geneviève fioraso à
rassurer la sénatrice en lui rappelons
le vaste plan annoncé ce matin par nadja
de vol vallaud belkacem et manuel valls
intitulé école et laïcité tous les
acteurs seront associés pour évidemment
m
les valeurs république
une au coeur de l'école autre question
qui a pu être abordé le problème des
inégalités entre les communes certaines
communes n'ont pas les moyens financiers
de mettre en oeuvre ses activités
périscolaires qui coûte je vous le
rappelle 150 euros environ par enfant et
par an nhs
alors c'est le cas de madame catherine
troendle ump catherine tremblay qui a
reproché à la ministre est bien d'avoir
des zones qui sont complètement soumise
à une inégalité dans l'application des
rythmes scolaires
la ministre s'est défendu en rappelant
que le fonds de soutien en commune avait
été pérennisée on a débloqué 400
millions d'euros par an pour les
communes a rappelé la secrétaire d'état
insuffisant pour l'ump cela ne suffira
pas à permettre aux communes qui n'ont
pas les moyens matériels d'assurer ces
temps périscolaire enfin de nombreux
sénateurs ont demandé un bilan pour
mesurer l'effet de l'application des
rythmes scolaires sur les communes
geneviève fioraso se refuse à faire un
bilan dans l'immédiat il est beaucoup
trop tôt dit la secrétaire d'état
en revanche c'est bien elle veut
rassurer les sénateurs en rappelant que
sur les 4000 premières communes qui ont
impliqué les rythmes scolaires et bien
les enseignements fondamentaux sont
mieux assimiler mieux positionnés et les
élèves plus attentifs voilà ce qu'il
fallait retenir de ces questions cribles
thématiques pour ma part je retrouve à
18 heures pour la reprise de la séance
de l'objet de deux parts de l'examen du
projet de loi notre nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république par les sénateurs très bonne
journée à vous sur les chaînes
parlementaires